The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: We'll begin this time
by looking at some probability
distribution that you
should be familiar
with from this
perspective, starting
with a Gaussian distribution
for one variable.
We're focused on a
variable that takes
real values in the interval
minus infinity to infinity
and the Gaussian has the
form exponential that
is centered around some
value, let's call it lambda,
and has fluctuations around this
value parameterized by sigma.
And the integral of
this p over the interval
should be normalized
to unity, giving you
this hopefully very
family of form.
Now, if you want to characterize
the characteristic function,
all we need to do is to
Fourier transform this.
So I have the integral
dx e the minus ikx.
So this-- let's remind
you alternatively
was the expectation value
of e to the minus ikx.
minus x minus lambda squared
over 2 sigma squared,
which is the probably
distribution.
And you should know what
the answer to that is,
but I will remind.
You can change variables to
x minus lambda [INAUDIBLE] y.
So from here we will
get the factor of 2
to the minus ik lambda.
You have then the
integral over y minus y
squared over 2 sigma squared.
And then what we need to do is
to complete this square over
here.
And you can do
that, essentially,
by adding and
subtracting a minus
k squared sigma squared over 2.
So that if I change variable
to y plus ik sigma squared,
let's call that z, then I
have outside the integral e
to the minus ik lambda minus k
squared sigma squared over 2.
And the remainder I can
write as a full square.
And this is just a
normalized Gaussian integral
that comes to 1.
So as you well know, a Fourier
transform of a Gaussian
is itself a Gaussian, and
that's what we've established.
E to the minus ik lambda minus
k squared sigma squared over 2m.
And if I haven't made a mistake
when I said k equals to 0,
the answer should be 1 because
k equals to 0 expectation
value of 1 just amounts
to normalization.
Now what we said was that
a more interesting function
is obtained by taking
the log of this.
So from here we go to the
log of [INAUDIBLE] of k.
Log of [INAUDIBLE] of k is
very simple for the Gaussian.
And what we had said
was that by definition
this log of the
characteristic function
generates cumulants
through the series
minus ik to the power of n over
n factorial, the end cumulant.
So looking at this,
we can immediately
see that the Guassian
is characterized
by a first cumulant, which is
the coefficient of minus ik.
It's lambda.
It is characterized by
a second cumulant, which
is the coefficient
of minus ik squared.
This, you know, is the variance.
And we can explicitly
see that the coefficient
of minus ik squared
over 2 factorial
is simply sigma squared.
So this is reputation.
But one thing that
is interesting
is that our series
has now terminates,
which means that
if I were to look
at the third cumulant, if I were
to look at the fourth cumulant,
and so forth, for the
Guassian, they're all 0.
So the Gaussian is
the distribution
that is completely
characterized just
by its first and second
cumulants, all the rest
being 0.
So, now our last
time we developed
some kind of a graphical method.
We said that I can graphically
describe the first cumulant
as a bag with one point in it.
Second cumulant with something
that has two points in it.
A third cumulant
with three three,
fourth cumulant with four
and four points and so forth.
This is just rewriting.
Now, the interesting
thing was that we
said that the various moments
we could express graphically.
So that, for example,
the second moment
is either this or this,
which then graphically
is the same thing as lambda
squared plus sigma squared
because this is indicated
by sigma squared.
Now, x cubed you
would say is either
three things by themselves
or put two of them
together and then one separate.
And this I could do in
three different ways.
And in general, for a
general distribution,
I would have had another
term, which is a triangle.
But the triangle is 0.
So for the Gaussian,
this terminates here.
I have lambda cubed plus
3 lambda sigma squared.
If I want to calculate
x to the fourth,
maybe the old way
of doing it would
have been too multiply the
Gaussian distribution against x
to the fourth and try
to do the integration.
And you would ultimately be able
to do that rearranging things
and looking at the various
powers of the Gaussian
integrated from minus
infinity to infinity.
But you can do it graphically.
You can say, OK.
It's either this or
I can have-- well,
I cannot put one aside
and three together,
because that doesn't exist.
I could have two together
and two not together.
And this I can do in
six different ways.
You can convince
yourself of that.
What I could do two pairs, which
I can do three different ways
because I can either do one,
two; one, three; one, four
and then the other is satisfied.
So this is lambda to the
fourth plus 6 lambda squared
sigma squared plus 3
sigma to the fourth.
And you can keep going and
doing different things.
OK.
Question?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is the
second-- [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: There?
AUDIENCE: Because-- so you said
that the second cumulative--
PROFESSOR: Oh.
AUDIENCE: --x sqaured.
Yes.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So that's the wrong--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: The coefficient of k
squared is the second cumulant.
The additional 2 was a mistake.
OK.
Anything else?
All right.
Let's take a look at couple
of other distributions,
this time discrete.
So the binomial distribution
is repeat a binary random
variable.
And what does this mean?
It means two outcomes
that's binary,
let's call them
A and B. And if I
have a coin that's head
or tails, it's binary.
Two possibilities.
And I can assign probabilities
to the two outcomes
to PA and PB, which
has to be 1 minus PA.
And the question
is if you repeat
this binary random
variables n times,
what is the probability
of NA outcomes of A?
And I forget to say
something important,
so I write it in red.
This should be independent.
That is the outcome of
a coin toss at, say,
the fifth time
should not influence
the sixth time and future times.
OK.
So this is easy.
The probability to have NA
occurrences of A in N trials.
So it has to be index yn.
Is that within the n times that
I tossed, A came up NA times.
So it has to be proportional
to the probability
of A independently multiplied
by itself NA times.
But if I have exactly
NA occurrences of A,
all the other times
I had B occurring.
So I have the probability
of B for the remainder,
which is N minus NA.
Now this is the probability
for a specific occurrence,
like the first NA times that
I threw the coin I will get A.
The remaining times
I would get B.
But the order is not
important and the number
of ways that I can
shuffle the order
and have a total of NA out of
N times is the binomial factor.
Fine.
Again, well known.
Let's look at its
characteristic function.
So p tilde, which is
now a function of k,
is expectation value
of e to the minus ik
NA, which means that I
have to weigh e minus ik
NA against the probability
of occurrences of NA times,
which is this binomial factor
PA to the power of NA, PB
to the power of N minus NA.
And of course, I have to sum
over all possible values of NA
that go all the way from 0 to N.
So what we have
here is something
which is this combination,
PA e to the minus ik
raised to the power of NA.
PB raised to the complement
N minus NA multiplied
by the binomial factor summed
over all possible values.
So this is just the definition
of the binomial expansion of PA
e to the minus ik plus PB
raised to the power of N.
And again, let's check.
If I set k equals to
0, I have PA plus PB,
which is 1 raised to the
power of N. So things are OK.
So this is the
characteristic function.
At this stage, the only thing
that I will note about this
is that if I look at the
characteristic function
I will get N times.
So this is-- actually,
let's make sure
that we maintain the
index N. So this is
the characteristic function
appropriate to N trials.
And what I get is that
up to factor of N,
I will get the
characteristic function
that would be
appropriate to one trial.
So what that means
if I were to look
at powers of k, the expectation
value of some cumulant,
if I go to repeat things
N times-- so this carries
an index N. It is going to be
simply N times what I would
have had in a single trial.
So for a single
trial, you really
have two outcomes-- 0 or 1
occurrences of this object.
So for a binary variable,
you can really easily compute
these quantities
and then you can
calculate the corresponding
ones for N trials simply
multiplying by N.
And we will see
that this is
characteristic, essentially,
of anything that is repeated N
times, not just the binomial.
So this form that you have
N independent objects,
you would get N
times what you would
have for one object
is generally valid
and actually something
that we will build
a lot of statistical
mechanics on because we
are interested in
the [INAUDIBLE].
So we will see that shortly.
But rather than
following this, let's
look at a third distribution
that is closely related,
which is the Poisson.
And the question
that we are asking
is-- we have an interval.
And the question is,
what is the probability
of m events in an
interval from 0 to T?
And I kind of
expressed it this way
because prototypical Poisson
distribution is, let's say,
the radioactivity.
And you can be waiting for
some time interval from 0
to 1 minute and asking within
that time interval, what's
the probability that you will
see m radioactive decay events?
So what is the probability
if two things happen?
One is that the probability of 1
and only 1 event in interval dt
is alpha dt as dt goes to 0.
OK?
So basically if you look
at this over 1 minute,
the chances are that you
will see so many events,
so many radioactivities.
If you shorten the
interval, the chances
that you would see events
would become less and less.
If you make your
event infinitesimal,
most of the time
nothing would happen
with very small
probability that vanishes.
As the size of the interval
goes to 0, you will see 1 event.
So this is one condition.
And the second condition is
events in different intervals
are independent.
And since I wrote
independent in red up there,
let me write it in red here
because it sort of harks back
to the same condition.
And so this is the question.
What is this probability?
And the to get the
answer, what we do
is to subdivide our
big interval into N,
which is big T divided by
the small dt subintervals.
So basically, originally
let's say on the time axis,
we were covering a distance
that went from 0 to big T
and we were asking
what happens here.
So what we are
doing now is we are
sort of dividing this interval
to lots of subintervals,
the size of each one
of them being dt.
And therefore, the total
number is big T over dt.
And ultimately,
clearly, I want to sit
dt going to 0 so that this
condition is satisfied.
So also because of the second
condition, each one of these
will independently tell me
whether or not I have an event.
And so if I want to count
the total number of events,
I have to add things
that are occurring
in different intervals.
And we can see that
this problem now
became identical to that
problem because each one
of these intervals has two
possible outcomes-- nothing
happens with probability
1 minus alpha dt,
something happens with
probability alpha dt.
So no event is probability
1 minus alpha dt.
One event means
probability alpha dt.
So this is a binomial process.
So we can calculate,
for example,
the characteristic function.
And I will indicate
that we are looking
at some interval of
size T and parameterized
by this straight
alpha, we'll see
that only the
product will occur.
So this is this before
Fourier variable.
We said that it's
a binary, so it
is one of the probabilities
plus e to the minus ik
plus the other probability
raised to the power of N.
Now we just substitute
the probabilities that we
have over here.
So the probability of not having
an event is 1 minus alpha dt.
The probability of having
an event is alpha dt.
So alpha dt is going
to appear here as e
to the minus ik minus 1.
So alpha st, e to the
minus ik, is from here.
From PB I will get
1 minus alpha dt.
And I bunched
together the two terms
that are proportional
to alpha dt.
And then I have to raise
to the power of N, which
is T divided by dt.
And this whole prescription
is valid in the limit
where dt is going to 0.
So what you have is 1
plus an infinitesimal
raised to a huge power.
And this limiting procedure
is equivalent to taking
the exponential.
So basically this
is the same thing
as exponential of what is here
multiplied by what is here.
The dt's cancel each
other out and the answer
is alpha T e to the
minus ik minus 1.
So the characteristic
function for this process
that we described is
simply given by this form.
You say, wait.
I didn't ask for the
characteristic function.
I wanted the probability.
Well, I say, OK.
Characteristic function is
simply the Fourier transform.
So let me Fourier
transform back,
and I would say that the
probability along not
the Fourier axis
but the actual axis
is open by the inverse
Fourier process.
So I have to do an
integral dk over 2 pi
e to the ikx times the
characteristic function.
And the characteristic function
is e to minus-- what was it?
e to the alpha T. E to
the minus ik k minus 1.
Well, there is an
equal to minus alpha
T that I can simply take
outside the integration.
I have the integration
over k e to that ikx.
And then what I will do
is I have this factor of e
to the something in the-- e to
the alpha T to the minus ik.
I will use the expansion
of the exponential.
So the expansion
of the exponential
is a sum over m running
from 0 to infinity.
The exponent raised
to the m-th power.
So I have alpha T raised
to the m-th power,
e to the minus ik raised
to the m-th power divided
m factor here.
So now I reorder the
sum and the integration.
The sum is over m, the
integration is over k.
I can reorder them.
So on the things
that go outside I
have a sum over m running from
0 to infinity e to the minus
alpha T, alpha T to the power
of m divided by m factorial.
Then I have the integral
over k over 2 pi e to the ik.
Well, I had the x here and I
have e to the minus ikm here.
So I have x minus m.
And then I say, OK, this is
an integral that I recognize.
The integral of e to
the ik times something
is simply a delta function.
So this whole thing
is a delta function
that's says, oh, x
has to be an integer.
Because I kind of did something
that maybe, in retrospect,
you would have said
why are you doing this.
Because along how many
times things have occurred,
they have either occurred
0 times, 1 times, 2 decays,
3 decays.
I don't have 2.5 decays.
So I treated x as a
continuous variable,
but the mathematics was really
clever enough to say that, no.
The only places that you can
have are really integer values.
And the probability that you
have some particular value
integer m is simply what we have
over here, e to the minus alpha
T alpha T to the power of m
divided by m factorial, which
is the Poisson distribution.
OK.
But fine.
So this is the
Poisson distribution,
but really we go
through the root
of the characteristic
function in order
to use this machinery
that we developed earlier
for cumulants et cetera.
So let's look at the
cumulant generating function.
So I have to take the
log of the function
that I had calculated there.
It is nicely in the
exponential, so I
get alpha T e to the
minus ik minus 1.
So now I can make an expansion
of this in powers of k
so I can expand the exponential.
The first term vanishes
because this starts with one.
So really I have alpha
T sum running from 1
to infinity or N running
from 1 to infinity minus ik
to the power of n
over n factorial.
So my task for
identifying the cumulants
is to look at the
expansion of this log
and read off powers of minus
ikn to the power of n factorial.
So what do we see?
We see that the first cumulant
of the Poisson is alpha T,
but all the coefficients
are the same thing.
The expectation value-- sorry.
The second cumulant is
alpha T. The third cumulant,
the fourth cumulant,
all the other cumulants
are also alpha T.
So the average number of decays
that you see in the interval
is simply alpha T. But
there are fluctuations,
and if somebody
should, for example,
ask you what's the average
number cubed of events,
you would say, OK.
I'm going to use the
relationship between moments
and cumulants.
I can either have
three first objects
or I can put one of
them separate in three
different factions.
But this is a case where
the triangle is allowed,
so diagrammatically
all three are possible.
And so the answer for the
first term is alpha T cubed.
For the second term,
it is a factor of 3.
Both this variance and the mean
give me a factor of alpha T,
so I will get alpha T squared.
And the third term, which
is the third cumulant,
is also alpha T. So the
answer is simply of this form.
Again, m is an integer.
Alpha T is dimensionless.
So there is no dimension problem
by it having different powers.
OK.
Any questions?
All right.
So that's what I wanted
to say about one variable.
Now let's go and look at
corresponding definitions
when you have
multiple variables.
So for many random variables,
the set of possible outcomes,
let's say, has variables x1, x2.
Let's be precise.
Let's end it a xn.
And if these are
distributed, each one of them
continuously over the
interval, to each point
we can characterize some kind
of a probability density.
So this entity is called the
joint probability density
function.
And its definition would be to
look at probability of outcome
in some interval that
is between, say, x1, x1
plus dx1 in one, x2, x2 plus
dx2 in the second variable.
xn plus dxn in
the last variable.
So you sort of look at
the particular point
in this multi-dimensional
space that you are interested.
You build a little
cube around it.
You ask, what's the
probability to being that cube?
And then you divide by
the volume of that cube.
So dx1, dx2, dxn,
which is the same thing
that you would be doing in
constructing any density
and by ultimately taking the
limit that all of the x's
go to 0.
All right.
So this is the joint
probability distribution.
You can construct, now, the
joint characteristic function.
Now how do you do that?
Well, again, just like you
would do for your transform
with multiple variables.
So you would go
for each variable
to a conjugate variable.
So x1 would go to k1.
x2 would go to k2.
xn would go to kn.
And this would
mathematically amount
to calculating the
expectation value of e
to the minus i k1x1 x1,
k2x2 and so forth, which
you would obtain by integrating
over all of these variables, e
to the minus ik alpha x alpha,
against the probability of x1
through xn.
Question?
AUDIENCE: It's a
bit hard to read.
It's getting really small.
PROFESSOR: OK.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: But it's just
multi-dimensional integral.
OK?
All right.
So this is, as
the case of one, I
think the problem is not the
size but the angle I see.
I can't do much for that.
You have to move to the center.
OK.
So what we can look at
now is joint moment.
So you can-- when
we had one variable,
we could look at something
like the expectation
value of x to the m.
That would be the m-th moment.
But if you have two
variable, we can raise x1
to some other, x2
to another power,
and actually xn
to another power.
So this is a joint moment.
Now the thing is, that
the same way that moments
for one variable
could be generated
by expanding the
characteristic function,
if I were to expand this
function in powers of k,
you can see that in meeting
the expectation value,
I will get various powers
of x1 to some power,
x2 to some power, et cetera.
So by appropriate
expansion of that function,
I can generate all of-- read
off all of these moments.
Now, a more common way of
generating the Taylor series
expansion is
through derivatives.
So what I can do is I can
take a derivative with respect
to, say, ik1.
If I take a derivative
with respect
to ik1 here, what happens
is I will bring down
a factor of minus x alpha.
So actually let me
put the minus so it
becomes a factor of x alpha.
And if I integrate x
alpha against this,
I will be generating
the expectation value
of x alpha provided that
ultimately I set all of the k's
to 0.
So I will calculate
the derivative
of this function with respect
to all of these arguments.
At the end of the day, I
will set k equals to 0.
That will give me the
expectation value of x1.
But I don't want x1, I want
x1 raised to the power of m1.
So I do this.
Each time I take a derivative
with respect to minus ik,
I will bring down the factor
of the corresponding x.
And I can do this with
multiple different things.
So d by the ik2 raised
to the power of m2
minus d by the ikn,
the whole thing
raised to the power of mn.
So I can either
take this function
of multiple variables--
k1 through kn--
and expand it and read off the
appropriate powers of k1k2.
Or I can say that the
terms in this expansion
are generated through taking
appropriate derivative.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is there
any reason why
you're choosing to take
a derivative with respect
to ikj instead of simply
putting the i in the numerator?
Or are there-- are there
things that I'm not--
PROFESSOR: No.
No.
There is no reason.
So you're saying why didn't I
write this as this like this?
i divided?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: I think
I just visually saw
that it was kind
of more that way.
But it's exactly the same thing.
Yes.
OK.
All right.
Now the interesting
object, of course, to us
is more the joint cumulants.
So how do we generate
joint cumulants?
Well previously, essentially
we had a bunch of objects
for one variable
that was some moment.
And in order to
make them cumulants,
we just put a sub C here.
So we do that and we are done.
But what did
operationally happen
was that we did the
expansion rather
than for the
characteristic function
for the log of the
characteristic function.
So all I need to do
is to do precisely
this set of derivatives
applied rather
than to the joint
characteristic function
to the log of the joint
characteristic function.
And at the end, set
all of the case to 0.
OK?
So by looking at these two
definitions and the expansion
of the log, for example, you
can calculate various things.
Like, for example, x1x2 with
a C is the expectation value
of x1x2.
This joint moment minus x1x2,
just as you would have thought,
would be the appropriate
generalization of the variance.
And this is the covariance.
And you can construct
appropriate extensions.
OK.
Now we made a lot of use of the
relationship between moments
and cumulants.
We just-- so the
idea, really, was
that the essence of a
probability distribution
is characterized
in the cumulants.
Moments kind of depend on
how you look at things.
The essence is in the cumulants,
but sometimes the moments
are more usefully
computed, and there
was a relationship between
moments and cumulants,
we can generalize that
graphical relation
to the case joint moments
and joint cumulants.
So graphical relation
applies as long
as points are labeled
by appropriate
or by corresponding variable.
So suppose I wanted to calculate
some kind of a moment that
is x1 squared.
Let's say x2, x3.
This may generate
for me many diagrams,
so let's stop from here.
So what I can do is
I can have points
that I label 1, 1, and 2.
And have them separate
from each other.
Or I can start
pairing them together.
So one possibility is that I
put the 1's together and the 2
starts separately.
Another possibility is that
I can group the 1 and the 2
together.
And then the other
1 starts separately.
But I had a choice of
two ways to do this,
so this comes-- this diagram
with an overall factor of 2.
And then there's the
possibility to put all of them
in the same bag.
And so mathematically,
that means
that the third-- this
particular joint moment
is obtained by taking average
of x1 squared x2 average, which
is the first term.
The second term is
the variance of x1.
And then multiplied by x2.
The third term is twice the
covariance of x1 and x2 times
the mean of x1.
And the final term is
just the third cumulant.
So again, you would need to
compute these, presumably,
from the law of the
characteristic function
and then you would be done.
Couple of other definitions.
One of them is an
unconditional probability.
So very soon we will be talking
about, say, probabilities
appropriate to the
gas in this room.
And the particles in
the gas in this room
will be characterized
where they are,
some position vector q, and
how fast they are moving,
some momentum vector p.
And there would be some kind
of a probability density
associated with finding a
particle with some momentum
at some location in space.
But sometimes I
say, well, I really
don't care about where
the particles are,
I just want to know how
fast they are moving.
So what I really care
is the probability
that I have a particle
moving with some momentum p,
irrespective of where it is.
Then all I need to
do is to integrate
over the position the joint
probability distribution.
And the check that
this is correct
is that if I first do not
integrate this over p,
this would be integrated
over the entire space
and the joint
probabilities appropriately
normalized so that the joint
integration will give me one.
So this is a correct
normalized probability.
And more generally, if I'm
interested in, say, a bunch of
coordinates x1 through xs, out
of a larger list of coordinates
that spans x1 through xs all
the way to something else,
all I need to do to get
unconditional probability is
to integrate over the variables
that I'm not interested.
Again, check is that it's
a good properly normalized.
Now, this is to
be contrasted with
the conditional probability.
The conditional
probability, let's
say we would be interested in
calculating the pressure that
is exerted on the board.
The pressure is exerted
by the particles that
impinge on the board
and then go away,
so I'm interested in the
momentum of particles
right at the board, not
anywhere else in space.
So if I'm interested in
the momentum of particles
at the particular location,
which could in principle depend
on location-- so now q is a
parameter p is the variable,
but the probability
distribution could depend on q.
How do we obtain this?
This, again.
is going to be proportional
to the probability
that I will find
a particle both at
this location with momentum p.
So I need to have that.
But it's not
exactly that there's
a normalization involved.
And the way to get
normalization is
to note that if I integrate this
probability over its variable p
but not over the parameter
q, the answer should be 1.
So this is going to
be, if I apply it
to the right-hand side,
the integral over p
of p of p and q,
which we recognize
as an example of an
unconditional probability
to find something at position 1.
So the normalization is going to
be this so that the ratio is 1.
So most generally, we
find that the probability
to have some subset
of variables, given
that the location of the
other variables in the list
are somewhat fixed, is given
by the joint probability of all
of the variables x1
through xn divided
by the unconditional
probability that that applies
to the parameters of our fixed.
And this is called
Bayes' theorem.
By the way, if variables
are independent,
which actually does apply
to the case of the particles
in this room as far as their
momentum and position is
concerned, then the
joint probability
is going to be the
product of one that
is appropriate to
the position and one
that is appropriate
to the momentum.
And if you have
this independence,
then what you'll
find is that there
is no difference between
conditional and unconditional
probabilities.
And when you go
through this procedure,
you will find that all the
joint cumulants-- but not
the joint moments, naturally--
all the joint cumulants
will be 0.
OK.
Any questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Could you explain
how the condition of p--
PROFESSOR: How
this was obtained?
Or the one above?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
The condition you applied
that the integral is 1.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So first of all, what
I want to look at
is the probability that
is appropriate to one
random variable at
the fixed value of all
the other random variables.
Like you say, in general I
should specify the probability
as a function of momentum and
position throughout space.
But I'm really interested
only at this point.
I don't really care
about other points.
However, the answer may depend
whether I'm looking at here
or I'm looking at here.
So the answer for the
probability of momentum
is parametrized by q.
On the other hand,
I say that I know
the probability over
the entire space
to be a disposition
with the momentum p
as given by this
joint probability.
But if I just set
that equal to this,
the answer is not
correct because the way
that this quantity is normalized
is if I first integrate over
all possible values
of its variable, p.
The answer should be 1,
irrespective of what q is.
So I can define a conditional
probability for momentum
here, a conditional
probability for momentum there.
In both cases the momentum
would be the variable it.
And integrating over all
possible values of momentum
should give me one for a
properly normalized probability
distribution.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Given
that q is something.
So q could be some--
now here q can
be regarded as some parameter.
So the condition is that this
integration should give me 1.
I said that on
physical grounds, I
expect this
conditional probability
to be the joint probability
up to some normalization
that I don't know.
OK.
So what is that normalization?
The whole answer should be 1.
What I have to do
is an integration
over momentum of the
joint probability.
I have said that an integration
over some set of variables
of a joint probability
will give me
the unconditional probability
for all the others.
So integrating over all momentum
of this joint probability
will give me the unconditional
probability for position.
So the normalization of 1 is
the unconditional probability
for position divided by n.
So n-- this has to be this.
And in general, it would
have to be this in order
to ensure that if
I integrate over
this first set of variables
of the joint probability
distribution which would
give me the unconditional,
cancels the unconditional in
the denominator to give me 1.
Other questions?
OK.
So I'm going to
erase this last board
to be underneath that
top board in looking
at the joint Gaussian
distribution.
So that was the
Gaussian, and we want
to look at the joint Gaussian.
So we want to
generalize the formula
that we have over there for one
variable to multiple variables.
So what I have there
initially is a factor, which
is exponential of minus
1/2, x minus lambda squared.
I can write this x
minus lambda squared
as x minus lambda
x minus lambda.
And then put the variance.
Let's call it is 1 over sigma
rather than a small sigma
squared or something like this.
Actually, let me
just write it as 1
over sigma squared
for the time being.
And then the normalization was
1 over root 2 pi sigma squared.
But you say, well, I
have multiple variables,
so maybe this is what I
would give for my B variable.
And then I would sum over
all N, running from 1 to N.
So this is essentially
the form that I
would have for an independent
Gaussian variables.
And then I would
have to multiply here
factors of 2 pi sigma squared,
so I would have 2 pi to the N
over 2.
And I would have
product of-- actually,
let's write it as 2 pi
to the N square root.
I would have the product
of sigma i squared.
But that's just too
limiting a form.
The most general form that these
quadratic will allow me to have
also cross terms where it is
not only the diagonal terms
x1 and x1 that's are multiplying
each other, but x2 and x3,
et cetera.
So I would have a sum over both
m and n running from 1 to n.
And then to coefficient
here, rather
than just being a number,
would be the variables
that would be like a matrix.
Because for each pair m and
n, I would have some number.
And I will call them the
inverse of some matrix C.
And if you, again, think
of the problem as a matrix,
if I have the diagonal
matrix, then the product
of elements along the
diagonal is the same thing
as the determinant.
If I were to rotate the matrix
to have off diagonal elements,
the determinant will
always be there.
So this is really
the determinant of C
that will appear here.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So are you inverting
the individual elements of C
or are you inverting the matrix
C and taking its elements?
PROFESSOR: Actually
a very good point.
I really wanted to write it
as the inverse of the matrix
and then peak the
mn [INAUDIBLE].
So we imagine that
we have the matrix.
And these are the
elements of some--
so I could have called
this whatever I want.
So I could have called the
coefficients of x and n.
I have chosen to regard
them as the inverse
of some other matrix C.
And the reason for that
becomes shortly clear,
because the covariances will
be related to the
inverse of this matrix.
And hence, that's the
appropriate way to look at it.
AUDIENCE: Can [INAUDIBLE]
what C means up there?
PROFESSOR: OK.
So let's forget
about this lambdas.
So I would have in
general for two variables
some coefficient for x1
squared, some coefficient
for x2 squared, and some
coefficient for x1, x2.
So I could call this a11.
I could call this a22.
I could call this 2a12.
Or actually I
could, if I wanted,
just write it as
a12 plus a21 x2x1
or do a1 to an a21
would be the same.
So what I could then
regard this is as x1 2.
The matrix a11, a12,
a21, a22, x1, x2.
So this is exactly
the same as that.
All right?
So these objects
here are the elements
of this matrix C inverse.
So I could call this x1,
x2 some matrix A x1 x2.
That A is 2 by 2 matrix.
The name I have given to that
2 by 2 matrix in C inverse.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: The matrix
is required to be
symmetric though, isn't it?
PROFESSOR: The
matrix is required
to be symmetric for
any quadrant form.
Yes.
So when I wrote it
initially, I wrote as 2 a12.
And then I said, well,
I can also write it
this fashion provided the
two of them are the same.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: How did you know
the determinant of C belonged
there?
PROFESSOR: Pardon?
AUDIENCE: How did you
know that the determinant
of C [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: OK.
How do I know the
determinant of C?
Let's say I give you this form.
And then I don't know
what the normalization is.
What I can do is I can do a
change of variables from x1 x2
to something like y1 y2 such
that when I look at y1 and y2,
the matrix becomes diagonal.
So I can rotate the matrix.
So any matrix I can imagine
that I will find some U such
that A U U dagger is this
diagonal matrix lambda.
Now under these procedures,
one thing that does not change
is the determinant.
It's always the product
of the eigenvalues.
The way that I set
up the problem,
I said that if I hadn't made
the problem to have cross terms,
I knew the answers to be the
product of that eigenvalues.
So if you like, I can start from
there and then do a rotation
and have the more general form.
The answer would stay
as the determinant.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: The matrix should
be positive as well or no?
PROFESSOR: The matrix should
be positive definite in order
for the probability to be
well-defined and exist, yes.
OK.
So if you like, by stating
that this is a probability,
I have imposed a
number of conditions
such as symmetry, as
well as positivity.
Yes.
OK.
But this is just linear algebra.
I will assume that you
know linear algebra.
OK.
So this property normalized
Gaussian joint probability.
We are interested in the
characteristic function.
So what we are interested is the
joint Gaussian characteristic.
And so again we
saw the procedure
was that I have to do
the Fourier transform.
So I have to take this
probability that I
have over there and do
an integration product,
say, alpha running
from 1 to N dx
alpha of e to the
minus ik alpha x alpha.
This product exists
for all values.
Then I have to multiply
with this probability
that I have up there,
which would appear here.
OK.
Now, again maybe an
easy way to imagine
is what I was saying
to previously.
Let's imagine that
I have rotated
into a basis where
everything is diagonal.
Then in the rotated
basis, all you need to do
is to essentially do product
of characteristic functions
such as what we have over here.
So the corresponding
product to this first term
would be exponential of
minus i sum over N running
from 1 to N k
alpha lambda alpha.
kn lambda n.
I guess I'm using n
as the variable here.
And as long as things
would be diagonal,
the next ordered
term would be a sum
over alpha kn squared the
corresponding eigenvalue
inverted.
So remember that in the diagonal
form, each one of these sigmas
would appear as the diagonal.
If I do my rotation,
essentially this term
would not be affected.
The next term would give me
minus 1/2 sum over m and n
rather than just having k1
squared k2 squared, et cetera.
Just like here, I
would have km kn.
What happened previously
was that each eigenvalue
would get inverted.
If you think about rotating a
matrix, all of its eigenvalues
are inverted, you are really
rotating the inverse matrix.
So this here would be the
inverse of whatever matrix
I have here.
So this would be C mn.
So I did will leave you to
do the corresponding linear
algebra here, but the
answer is correct.
So the answer is that the
generator of cumulants
for a joint Gaussian
distribution
has a form which has a bunch of
the linear terms-- kn lambda n.
And a bunch of
second order terms,
so we will have minus
1/2 sum over m and n km
kn times some coefficient.
And the series terminates here.
So for the joint Gaussian,
you have first cumulant.
So the expectation
value of nm cumulant
is the same thing as lambda m.
You have covariances or second
cumulants xm, xn, C is Cmn.
And in particular,
the diagonal elements
would correspond
to the variances.
And all the higher orders
are 0 because there's
no further term
in the expansion.
So for example, if I were to
calculate this thing that I
have on the board here for
the case of a Gaussian,
for the case of the Gaussian, I
would not have this third term.
So the answer that
I would write down
for the case of the
third term would
be something that
didn't have this.
And in the way that we
have written things,
the answer would
have been x1 squared
x2-- would be just a
lambda 1 squared lambda
2 plus sigma 1 squared,
or let's call it
C11, times lambda 2
plus 2 lambda 1 C12.
And that's it.
So there is something
that follows from this
that it is used a
lot in field theory.
And it's called Wick's theorem.
So that's just a
particular case of this,
but let's state it anyway.
So for Gaussian distributed
variables of 0 mean,
following condition applies.
I can take the first
variable raised
to power n1, the
second variable to n2,
the last variable
to some other nN
and look at a joint
expectation value such as this.
And this is 0 if sum
over alpha and alpha
is odd and is called sum
over all pairwise contraction
if a sum over alpha
and alpha is even.
So actually, I have right
here an example of this.
If I have a Gaussian
variable-- jointly
distributed Gaussian variables
where the means are all 0-- so
if I say that lambda
1 and lambda 2 are 0,
then this is an odd
power, x1 squared x2.
Because of the symmetry
it has to be 0,
but you explicitly see
that every term that I have
will be multiplying some
power of [INAUDIBLE].
Whereas if for
other than this, I
was looking at something
like x1 squared x2 x3
where the net power
is even, then I
could sort of
imagine putting them
into these kinds of diagrams.
Or alternatively, I can
imagine pairing these things
in all possible ways.
So one pairing would
be this with this,
this with this, which would have
given me x1 squared C x2 x3 C.
Another pairing would
have been x1 with x2.
And then, naturally, x1 with x3.
So I would have gotten
x1 with x2 covariance x1
with extreme x3 covariance.
But I could have connected
the x1 to x2 or the second x1
to x2.
So this comes in 2 variance.
And so the answer here would
be C11 C23 plus 2 C1 2 C13.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: In your writing
of x1 to the n1 [INAUDIBLE].
It should be the
cumulant, right?
Or is it the moment?
PROFESSOR: This is the moment.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: The contractions
are the covariances.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: So the point is
that the Gaussian distribution
is completely characterized
in terms of its covariances.
Once you know the
covariances, essentially you
know everything.
And in particular, you may be
interested in some particular
combination of x's.
And then you use to
express that in terms
of all possible
pairwise contractions,
which are the covariances.
And essentially, in
all of field theory,
you expand around some kind
of a Gaussian background
or Gaussian 0 toward the result.
And then in your
perturbation theory
you need various
powers of your field
or some combination of
powers, and you express them
through these kinds
of relationships.
Any questions?
OK.
This is fine.
Let's get rid of this.
OK.
Now there is one result that
all of statistical mechanics
hangs on.
So I expect that
as I get old and I
get infirm or whatever
and my memory vanishes,
the last thing that I
will remember before I die
would be the central
limit theorem.
And why is this important
is because you end up
in statistical physics
adding lots of things.
So really, the question that
you have or you should be asking
is thermodynamics is
a very precise thing.
It says that heat
goes from the higher
temperature to
lower temperature.
It doesn't say it does that 50%
of the time or 95% of the time.
It's a definite statement.
If I am telling you
that ultimately I'm
going to express everything
in terms of probabilities,
how does that jive?
The reason that it jives
is because of this theorem.
It's because in order to go from
the probabilistic description,
you will be dealing with
so many different-- so many
large number of variables--
that probabilistic statements
actually become precise
deterministic statements.
And that's captured
by this theorem, which
says that let's look at the
sum of N random variables.
And I will indicate the sum
by x and my random variables
as small x's.
And let's say that this is, for
the individual set of things
that I'm adding up
together, some kind
of a joint probability
distribution
out of which I take
these random variables.
So each instance of this sum is
selected from this joint PDF,
so x itself is a random variable
because of possible choices
of different xi from this
probability distribution.
So what I'm interested is what
is the probability for the sum?
So what is the p that
determines this sum?
I will go by the root of these
characteristic functions.
I will say, OK, what's the
expectation value of-- well,
let's-- what's the Fourier
transform of this probability
distribution?
If we transform, by definition
it is the expectation of e
to the minus ik this big X,
which is the sum over all off
the small x's.
Do I have that
definition somewhere?
I erased it.
Basically, what is this?
If this k was, in fact,
different k's-- if I had a k1
multiplying x1,
k2 multiplying x2,
that would be the definition
of the joint characteristics
function for this joint
probability distribution.
So what this is is you take the
joint characteristic function,
which depends on k1
k2, all the way to kn.
And you set all of
them to be the same.
So take the joint
characteristic function
depends on N Fourier variables.
Put all of them the same k
and you have that for the sum.
So I can certainly do
that by adding a log here.
Nothing has changed.
I know that the log is the
generator of the cumulants.
So this is a sum
over, let's say, n
running from 1 to
infinity minus ik
to the power of n
over n factorial,
the joint cumulant of the sum.
So what is the
expansion that I would
have for log of the joint
characteristic function?
Well, typically I would say have
at the lowest order k1 times
the mean of the first
variable, k2 times
the mean of the second variable.
But all of them are the same.
So the first order,
I would get minus i
the same k sum over n
of the first cumulant
of the N-th variable.
Typically, this
second order term,
I would have all
kinds of products.
I would have k1 k3 k2 k4,
as well as k1 squared.
But now all of them
become the same,
and so what I will have
is a minus ik squared.
But then I have all possible
pairings mn of xm xn cumulants.
AUDIENCE: Question.
PROFESSOR: Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
expression you probably
should use different
indices when you're
summing over elements
of Taylor serious
and when you're summing
over your [INAUDIBLE]
random variables.
Just-- it gets confusing
when both indexes are n.
PROFESSOR: This here, you
want me to right here, say, i?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: OK.
And here I can write i and j.
So I think there's
still a 2 factorial.
And then there's higher orders.
Essentially then, matching
the coefficients of minus ik
from the left minus
ik from the right
will enable me to calculate
relationships between cumulants
of the sum and cumulants of
the individual variables.
This first one of them is
not particularly surprising.
You would say that
the mean of the sum
is sum of the means of
the individual variables.
The second statement is
that the variance of the sum
really involves a pair, i
and j, running from 1 to N.
So if these variable
were independent,
you would be just
adding the variances.
Since they are
potentially dependent,
you have to also keep
track of covariances.
And this kind of summation
extends to higher and higher
cumulants, essentially
including more and more powers
of cumulants that you
would put on that side.
And what we do
with that, I guess
we'll start next time around.